[Musique]
non
mais
j'ai vu ce qui est arrivé au 4e régiment
quand il ya le hockey et ses chiens les
ont attrapé il n'en restait pas je vous
interdis de rien il n'en restait pas
assez de ces pauvres hommes pour pouvoir
les enterrer
comprenez bien que lorsqu on baisse la
garde une seconde
on est tous à leur merci je hais ces
hommes
et la guerre m'a donné tout un tas de
raisons de l'est aïe
[Musique]
capitaine vous connaissez le chef les
locaux l'armée veut être sûr que ce chef
va bien rentrés dans le montana sans
aucun incident cet indien
ce qu'il a fait
c'est un boucher
alors vous devriez bien vous entends je
les ai et la guerre m'a donné des tonnes
de résoudre l'énigme
j'ai tué des sauvages parce que c'est
mon travail
est ce que vous croyez en dieu josé
oui j'y crois il ferme les yeux sur ce
qui se passe ici depuis très longtemps
[Musique]
j'ai tué tout ce qui pouvait marcher ou
rampes et à force de le faire
c'est vêtue
c'est bien ce qu'il fait
ressens-tu
tous les thèmes
on pourrait facilement être vous assis
là avec ses chefs
parfois je vis le caractère définitif de
la mort
certitude
je doit chasser ses pensées qui me
viennent lorsque je suis fait
avait occulté
dessous à la guerre